lockdown is easing in Thailand but the
lights are still off in pitayas once
bustling party district it's here in the
cities bars sex worker anna used to meet
most of her clients party a sleepy
neighborhood leave and now is very quiet
this is what walking street looks like
in the past attracting millions of
visitors every year
but in march thailand declared a state
of emergency due to covert 19 clubs and
bars are now shut tourists have gone
business has dried up is this the
hardest it's been yes very hard hottest
in my life because I never seen
something like this before
when I work I get money from tourists
and now no health tourists I not have
the money how I can survive how I can
alive it's estimated between a hundred
thousand and up to a million people here
in Thailand gets some sort of money from
the sex trade but overnight the bars
closed the income stopped there was no
warning prostitution may be illegal in
Thailand but charities say there are
fifty thousand sex workers in Pattaya
nyan one sells sex on the street alone
at night they're isolated and vulnerable
you know Daniel eight people a single
mom with a young daughter and a nephew
to feed this is a devastating situation
for me sixty percent of sex workers here
are mothers they say they have no other
way to feed their families how worried
are you about catching the corona virus
from a client and I long to try to
reduce the risk local charities swing is
designing covert safe sex kids we have
to spay alcohol spray on the beer this
is the type of general anti bacterial
shower gel do we have to add all the
customers have to take a shower with
this we are scared I can say we are
scared about the koete but we cannot
stop work swing is also giving out
almost 3000 free meals a week two
struggling sex workers
the government says it's helping to find
jobs and housing some have managed to
get financial aid but things have never
been this difficult this time is not
just only distressful till we die we
make the people who are in behind them
with I also die because they don't have
income to to survive themselves the
people they are hungry they need a food
Saudi huh sawadika and is now making
what she can selling jewelry on the
internet to tighter oppa I got a bad car
but kovat 19 has pushed many to breaking
point the sex industry may bring in
billions of dollars a year here but the
work as it depends on have no rights no
recognition and now some are fighting to
survive
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Pattaya
Thailand